- [Voiceover] Hey fellas,
you doing all that cursing.
But do you even know where
those words came from?
It's The Origins of Curse Words.
Fuck. For example, "Oh, a red light.
"Well, fuck it."
Fuck is thought to be
in relation to the words
to move back and forth and to strike,
from Swedish, German and Dutch languages.
It was used in a coded poem around 1475AD.
And when decoded, roughly translates to:
They are not in heaven because
they fuck the wives of Ely.
Historically the first throw of shade.
And bitch.
Not something you always called Lassie.
The direct origins of the
word are questionable.
Likely first used as
an insult against women
in the 14th and 15th Century.
Bad move, Billy.
Where twerking came from... ass.
With the official definition being
the description of a donkey.
And that's what we call
from assy to classy.
How could we forget shit.
Originally not a bad word at all.
"Gee whizz, Becky, your
dribbling sure is shit."
Coming from Old English, German and Dutch.
And we can't forget damn.
For example if Stacey said,
"Damn, Billy, when you gonna let me
get a piece of that ass."
There you go, Stacey.
Damn comes from a latin word,
to condemn or to inflict loss on.
The term is associated with hell.
And it was popularized
by 18th Century poet,
Alexander Pope, with the phrase,
"Damn with faint praise."
Thanks for joining us, and
we'll see you next time
on The Origins of Curse Words.